what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today from corridor
crew love this channel spider-man with
an r-rated
raid t spider-man
these are always fun i love when they
make these renditions while doing a
spider-man re-watch i'm sure this is
going to feel particularly cathartic in
some way all right guys let's get to
we're not going to watch like the super
long version where you watch them
assembling we're watching that the clip
down one the four minute one that's up
on their channel
[Music]
a mobius by the way i specialize in
erasing undesirable realities in
multiverse and this clean cut peter
parker just created a whole mess of
undesirable
i mean he made
timelines that contain some of the most
incompetent spider-man the tva has ever
seen
i'm gonna prune every last one of them
oh no
oh
kelly oh
no
no
no
whoa
[Music]
sorry i'm beautiful
yeah i'm corner created right crazy
yes you are sir
[Music]
[Music]
thin skin tone
do you have a train to catch
oh god
it's going to be the thumbnail bumper
there oh no no no no no no
oh my god
[Music]
you got a few
yeah
oh oh god no
god
we're slowing down
yes
oh this is gonna be disgusting isn't it
no
[Music]
do whiplash
[Music]
you can't prune this guy
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes
yes oh god no
i enjoy the
crap out of that one they actually made
a little storyline out of it and the
before the ones that we've seen well it
wasn't a couple of the other ones i
don't know how many they've done but i
don't recall them actually doing a
storyline for them well i might be
mistaken but taking loki hopping through
the timelines to stop these terrible
spider-man variants the escalation of
how it all came about so i like that you
actually have a mobius going around what
i really noticed is that before when we
watch them the violence is undercut by
you can hear the corridor crew laughing
or you're cutting to them yeah when you
just stay in the story in the violence
and then as it's especially building
when the list gets getting crossed off
mobius is becoming like more gleeful and
they're like oh yeah yeah keep killing
keep killing it it actually makes for a
really weird sadistic short film which
makes it funnier because of how
sick it is
yeah
absolutely it almost seems like more
mobius is getting some kind of twisted
pleasure out of doing his job and doing
it well and i mean yeah this just
escalated worse and i know it's like he
doesn't have anything to do with the way
the method in which they're dying but at
the same time there is some kind of like
extra magical reality that kind of
descends upon everything as these deaths
get more and more outlandish and
ridiculous i mean the explosion of what
does it splatterman or whatever i think
that was the one that you know it's the
first one so it's easy to point out but
that was just such a beautifully
rendered splat effect and then to watch
like his arm muscles ripping apart and
and two i mean i like that they further
built in that humor i mean you know they
did their anatomically correct
spider-man video which they referenced
here and then to kind of carry that on
and do it subtle or not
not subtle at all a weird twist with uh
spider-man 2 where he's got web shooters
in his feet also and now he's like doing
the splits and you think it's just going
to end with his arms ripping off and
then they you know go that looney tunes
step or two further and the whole train
crashes down and it's just it's like
just create a brand new thing yeah it's
just like this cruel alternate reality
where the worst case scenario will
always take place and yeah i feel like
the older ones were more like here's a
medley of clips that we gussied up to be
more rated where yeah this slowed really
nicely and then you had to have bully
mcguire penis parker come out on top at
the end cute makes perfect sense cute
cute's the word it's cute for in context
huge as cute as anything in this
universe could be i think that's what
also made it even better is because i
was just expecting like the most obvious
gore gags it started off that way like
okay yeah it's easy like when toby from
spider-man one he's gonna crash through
the wall he's gonna pull up he's gonna
explode you know yeah like the
helicopter from spider-man homecoming
he's gonna fall into that they got like
really creative with the way like how
the scenes would actually unfold like
you were bringing up the train sequence
in particular but i just like the the
wacky inventions they made along the way
and they even managed to put on a fight
scene with mobius and bully mcguire yeah
they made a fight suit and i mean that
too like in the ingenuity of like i know
you had to go through and source the
right mobius moments and it felt even
though you can tell he stitched in all
these scenes like it was for the
confines of this as a sketch it works
really well yeah surprisingly man all
right guys well subscribe to corridor
crew watch them if i wanna or their
their full video of how they made it or
something i'm probably watching my own
time hit that like button and hey let's
do a paint
chris wamoff the reason why i wanted to
shout out chris whamoff is because he is
one of the most kind people in the world
so merry christmas to you buddy but with
someone who is as generous as giving and
has as much heart as yourself who's
constantly trying to help out the
underdogs the people who are in need i
can imagine that comes with a lot of
rage so i was looking at the list of
people of who to shout out who is the
one who probably has the most
internalized the most bile built up
within them that needs to unleash some
r-rated violence it's you so chris go
out there wham off all over the streets
just let him have it because at the end
of the day you're not gonna get rich
doing what you're doing when does being
kind lead to wealth you're going to get
[ __ ] over in the end so you might as
well have some glorious rampages fun
when you're out there create some havoc
buddy and if chris ends up going through
with this i want everyone to know
that this is a joke
yes but i still want credit
for the massacre yeah
[Music]